learn how to use terraform with aws in
this course from derrick morgan you'll
realize within a few minutes of watching
how amazing derek is as an instructor
hello and welcome to the build a
development environment with aws in
terraform resume foundations project
so a resume foundations project is a
short project that is tailored to cover
the important aspects of a technology
in order to help you build the
foundations necessary to build your own
projects and apply them to your resumes
so let's take a look at what you're
going to find in the course
in this two hour project centered around
terraform you're going to use vs code
and deploy an aws ec2 instance along
with the vpc internet gateway security
groups etc that will serve as a remote
development environment that you can log
into directly from vs code
we'll utilize several terraform tools
and functions such as terraform state
format replace console variables
conditionals file template file and more
we'll also use aws user data and a local
exec provisioner to bootstrap the ec2
instance and add its connection
information to your vs code ssh
configuration file allowing you to
modify it for your own projects
since we'll make heavy use of
documentation and highlight the process
behind developing a brand new terraform
deployment
you'll have the skills you need to dive
deeper into terraform and add this
extremely in-demand skill to your resume
so what are you waiting for
sign up today and don't forget to
terraform apply yourself
so let's start out right here in the aws
console
and let's go to i am
now as you can see i've recently visited
but just in case you haven't you can
just search right up here in the search
bar
let's click on that
and now let's click on users
now within users you may see a lot more
information here i've actually hidden
most of mine let's go ahead and create a
new user
so we'll click on add users
and for the username feel free to use
whatever you'd like i'm just going to
call it vs code
and now i'm going to choose access key
programmatic access we're not bothering
with a password this is not going to be
a user that logs into the console
so go ahead and click that
and next permissions
now as you can see i've got a group of
admins you can of course create a new
group or you can just attach the
policies directly
and i'm going to do that just click on
attach existing policies directly
click on administrator access
and then click next tags
now feel free to tag it if you'd like to
i'm not going to bother
and next review we've got right here our
username programmatic access
and administrator access
go ahead and click on create user
and right here you'll see that you've
got your access key id and your secret
access key
go ahead and download that csv
as you can see i've already installed
visual studio code it was a pretty
straightforward process i am on a
windows machine
but this of course will also work on a
mac or linux so go ahead and first
things first let's get the aws extension
installed
so click on the extensions icon here on
the left
and then search for aws
and once you've done that we've got this
aws toolkit here go ahead and click
install
looks like everything installed fine so
i'm going to go ahead and close this
pane
and close this tab
and then i'm going to click on this
little aws icon
as you can see we've got connect to aws
right here but before we can do that we
need to get some credentials installed
so head up to view and command palette
then as you can see i've searched for
this before but if you need to get to it
you can type aws and then start typing
create credentials profile just like so
and then open that and as you can see
here i've got a credentials profile
called vs code if yours looks different
make sure that you get this looking the
same if you want to follow along in the
course exactly but of course if you
don't or you're comfortable making
simple modifications you can name this
whatever you'd like but what we need to
do is populate this aws access key id in
secret access key so go ahead and open
your credentials file and paste this
information in
just like so
alright and once you've done that go
ahead and control s to save this file
you should not have this white dot that
was up here before and close this tab
and then click on connect to aws
and you should see your profile right
here if not you can obviously type
profile
vs code
if you need to and just click on that
and default region of us east one
i actually don't want that region i'm
going to use a different one but
whichever region you choose you can
choose that here
i'm just going to say no
and i'm going to add
us west
2
that's a region i typically use in my
courses because there's so much default
stuff that goes on in us east one i just
prefer to stick with us west 2 but this
is totally up to you so once you've done
that you can go ahead and minimize that
and then open the extensions panel again
let's go ahead and add something that
will give us a little terraform syntax
highlighting let's go ahead and type in
terraform and as you can see there is an
official terraform extension here it's
rated 2.5 it is pretty buggy it might be
better now that you're watching this
video feel free to choose this one if
you'd like but i'm actually going to use
this one here it's just got a higher
rating and it's been pretty consistent
for me so i'm going to install this one
just like so
alright and i'm going to close that tab
and close my extensions so now that
we've got our extensions installed let's
go ahead and create our working
directory so i'm going to go ahead and
click on open folder and i'm just going
to set mine up in the documents
directory feel free to set this up
wherever you'd like of course just like
so and then i'm going to create a new
directory
and i'm just going to call it terraform
just like so
alright and i'm going to open that
and hit select folder just like so
alright so now we have a working
directory we've got our extensions
installed everything is ready to start
the course now it's a fairly
straightforward build we're going to cut
it down to the bare necessities because
you don't need much for your development
environment the more resources we add
the more can go wrong so let's just make
sure that we keep it as small as
possible and then of course as you
develop new requirements you can build
out your environment to meet your needs
from there so what we're going to do is
we're going to use vs code on our
terminal and then we're going to use the
terraform configuration files providers
variables main
which of course we will be explaining
all of these throughout the course and
then we've got a configuration file here
that's going to configure vs code
based on the ip and other information of
our developer node and we've got our
user data that's going to bootstrap that
node now in aws we will build out a vpc
we're going to build out an internet
gateway public route table
a security group a public subnet and an
ec2 instance so all of this together
will form our developer environment
and once we're done
after all of these files have been
processed and everything is good to go
your vs code terminal will have access
directly to this ec2 node to deploy a
remote ssh session
which will allow you to have file and
ssh access to your ec2 node to run
whatever you need so that's a very high
level overview let's go ahead and get
building
so here i am in the aws provider
documentation within terraform and a
provider is basically used by terraform
to interface with the api of whatever
infrastructure you're trying to build
so in this case you're trying to build
aws infrastructure so you use the aws
provider if you're using gcp or azure or
vmware or whatever else you will use
their respective providers so as you can
see it's pretty straightforward since
we've already provided credentials we
don't need to provide those within the
provider block here
if you scroll down you can see there's
actually lots of ways to add these
credentials but again we already have a
profile so all we need to do is access
the shared credentials file
just like this so let's go ahead
and we'll keep it fairly simple i'm just
going to copy this here
and then within our terraform directory
here which we created earlier going to
create a new file and let's call this
providers.tf
just like so
and we'll paste that in now i'm actually
going to remove this version block here
because you may be in the distant future
and not on version 3 anymore so again
i'm going to just remove that and let
you download whatever version is current
now after that
we need to add our provider block that
is the required providers block and that
provides configuration that terraform
needs to know about
but the provider block itself provides
the information needed to access aws
specifically
so if you scroll down here you can
actually see that we have some usage
examples and we have one right here with
shared credentials file already here for
us so let's go ahead and just copy this
one
and i'm going to paste that
right here now again typically i'd type
all of this out but since this is a very
quick course i want to make sure it is
as streamlined as possible for you so
here i'm just going to remove this and
i'm just going to add that little
squiggly right there to indicate the
home directory
dot aws
slash
credentials
because that's where our credentials
file is stored
now if you've moved it of course you'll
want to change this but this is actually
the default for windows and mac so you
should be good to go now for the profile
remember that was named vs code
and the region is us west 2. so this is
what you should have here for the
provider again if the documentation did
not provide this exactly of course just
copy it from here all right so now that
that's done let's go ahead and run a
terraform init to initialize this and
connect to aws to ensure everything
works out so i'm going to click on
terminal
and new terminal just like so
let's go ahead and i'm going to pull
this up a little bit
clear this screen and let's go ahead and
run terraform init
all right terraform has been
successfully initialized as you can see
we've got hashicorp aws version
3.71.0 at least that's my version if
your version is different that is
perfectly fine also you can see that
terraform has created a lock file
terraform lock.hcl
and what that's going to do is ensure
that the version is frozen
again you can change this if you'd like
and this should be the current version
you're using but this is something you
might want to keep in your github or
gitlab or wherever you're storing your
code repository so that you can ensure
that every time you run this code it
always uses the same version of the
provider and you have a much lower risk
of having some sort of issue with an
upgrade so it looks like everything is
all nice and initialized as you can see
here i can do this drop down
and you can actually see the provider
which for windows is an exe and for
linux and mac you'll actually see
another binary there but this is
compiled and you're not going to go
digging through it as you can see here
the vpc is actually pretty
straightforward you basically specify
the resource this being the actual
resource as you can see aws vbc this is
a static value that cannot be changed if
you change this you're not going to
deploy a vpc now after that we've got
the name for this vpc which in this case
is main we can name it whatever it is we
want this is a logical name that only
terraform knows about so this isn't
going to show up in aws anywhere so
again make sure you understand that but
this is how we will reference this vpc
in future lessons and then we just
provide a cider block now there are also
lots of other options that you can
specify here as you can see it gets
pretty complicated if you go down to the
argument reference you can see that we
have a lot of stuff here we can use such
as enable dns support which defaults to
true and enable dns host names which
defaults to false so let's go ahead and
let's utilize this to create a vpc i'm
going to bring my vs code back over here
and i'm going to create a new file and
we're going to call that
main.tf so i'll create a new file
main.tf just like so make sure that it
is in the proper directory here and you
didn't accidentally add it within the
terraform directory here and we've got
that up now the way these tf files are
processed is they're processed as if
they're all the same file so if you have
20 tf files in here all with different
resources they're all going to be
processed as if they're the same file so
keep that in mind you can split up your
code however makes sense to you you can
have a compute.tf networking.tf whatever
you'd like it's all processed the same
as long as it's in the same directory so
let's go ahead and create this vpc
resource so i'm going to type resource
aws vpc just like so so this of course
is specifying that i want a resource
where here i wanted a provider
here i want a resource
now once again let's name this vpc i'm
going to name it mtc for more than
certified vpc just like so and then i'm
going to use some curly braces here this
will wrap our entire resource then i
want to specify that cider block
and in my case i'm going to do
10.123.0.0
16. if you've taken my other courses
you've probably seen this cider block
before now under that let's say i want
to
enable dns host names
as you remember dns hostnames defaults
to false so if i want to enable this i
need to make sure that i add it
so i'll go ahead and enable
dns hostnames
equals true just like so and if i wanted
to i can also say enable dns
support equals true
now we don't have to because this is
assumed however depending on your
development team you might want to
ensure that this is explicitly mentioned
your team may not understand what's
default for your vpc and it might be
very helpful to be very explicit and
specify some things that default is true
as true just to ensure that one it's
easy to modify and two your team knows
that this is enabled again not required
but it's something you might want to do
now under that we're going to specify
some tags
and i just want a name for it and i'm
just going to name it dev just like so
so i know that this is my dev vpc
whenever i go searching alright as you
can see i've got my two curly braces
here one is to enclose these tags and
one is to enclose this resource so
that's all i need there let's go ahead
and run a terraform plan just like so
and what this is going to do is let us
know what we're trying to build
just like so as you can see we've got
all of these new pieces that are going
to be created within our vpc resource
we're going to have our cider block an
arm will be created which we won't know
until we actually apply it and the same
with a lot of this other information
such as the id we will not know until we
apply it now as you can see we've got
these green plus marks that means that
these are all being added so that all
looks good we've got one actual resource
awsvpc.mtc vpc to add so what we want to
do next is apply we'll run a terraform
apply just like so
and as you can see it basically runs
another plan
and then asks us to confirm
and to confirm i'm going to type yes
scroll this up a little bit
and our vpc is being created
all right perfect our apply is now
complete so if we go over here to our
aws pane
i'm going to click no here i do not need
us east one right now because i am in us
west i'm then going to click on
resources
and as you can see i've actually got
some resources already shown here that's
from a previous installation if you
click on this little sprocket
type aws colon colon ec2 colon colon vpc
you can also search for vpc you can see
that that's been added go ahead and
check mark that
and click ok
to ensure that resource is added then if
you click on it
you'll see our brand new vpc
is here
so there's our cider block our default
network acl
default security group it looks like
everything is here enable dns host names
is true enable dns support is true we're
going to take a slight detour from
building to dive into the terraform
state a bit so we better understand how
information about our deployment is
stored for terraform to use this is
probably one of the most important
concepts with terraform so make sure you
read over the documentation a good bit
if you really want to understand how
things work but essentially we're just
going to take a look here and see
exactly what is stored in our state as
we deploy resources as you can see
there's a lot here in the docs
and we're going to explore several
pieces of this as we build our
infrastructure
so here we are right here after we have
now deployed our fresh new vpc as you
remember in our aws resources pane here
you can see all of this wonderful
information about our vpc now another
way we can see what we've deployed
is to head into our explorer and right
here our terraform.tf state file as you
can see we have a lot of the same
information default network acl default
route table id security group id the vpc
id there as you can see all of that is
here
ppc id default network acl security
group etc now it's formatted a little
bit differently but it's for the most
part the same information and this was
all pulled right from the aws api so now
typically you're not going to want to
traverse this tf state manually as it
will normally be stored somewhere
offsite whether it's in terraform cloud
or in aws or somewhere else so we have
several different tools we can use
command line tools to access the state
so let's take a look
at terraform
state list just like so
as you can see we only have one piece in
our state one resource that mtc vpc that
we deployed so if i want to see that
information within that vpc
i can run a terraform state show aws
vpc.mtc
vpc
as you can see shown right here
if i hit enter on that
we have all of the same information
so we've got information here from our
api we've got information here within
our state the state file specifically
but this is all the same information
it's just formatted a little bit
differently now you can output as json
and
really manipulate that output but we're
not going to dive into that right now
alright and of course if you want to see
the entire state all you have to do is
just type terraform show
so keep that in mind
terraform state show requires you to
insert a resource
now terraform show is just going to show
you everything that you've got which of
course can be
massive if you have a very large
environment
so those are the basics of our state and
the information that's being stored
within it
there are a lot of commands that you can
use to manipulate that state to refresh
it to migrate it
but we're not going to dive into that
right now but just know it'll be very
beneficial to you if you dive into the
documentation a little bit and just read
all about state as it is the most
important feature within terraform we're
going to check out a command almost as
fun to use as terraform apply but much
more fun to say and that command is
terraform destroy so terraform destroy
is pretty straightforward
basically it's going to destroy anything
that we have created and as you can see
here
you can actually run a terraform applied
dash destroy
but we typically just use terraform
destroy there's not a lot else going on
here that you need to really worry about
you can run a terraform plan in destroy
mode which will tell you what happens
when you destroy so that can be fairly
useful if you need to test something out
but for the most part we're just going
to run this terraform destroy so let's
do that let's knock out this vpc that we
created completely delete everything we
have applied
so just run terraform destroy
and then we can just use a dash auto
approve if we don't want that
confirmation dialog again useful in
automation probably wouldn't use this in
production if you're typing it yourself
though
let's go ahead and run that
all right the destruction is complete
everything is gone so that's really all
you need to know there so go ahead and
reapply it as we're going to need this
vpc for pretty much the remainder of the
course so terraform apply
auto approve just like so
all right all set we're back to where we
left off you saw how easy that was this
is one of the great things about
terraform
infrastructure just comes and goes as
you need it we're going to deploy a
subnet to which we can deploy our future
ec2 instance as you can see here in the
docs it's pretty straightforward
although there are a few more options
we're going to want to add one of them
and if you scroll down here is map
public ip on launch
default is false we want to make sure
that our instance receives a public ip
address whenever we launch into the
subnet so we'll want to ensure we add
that so let's go ahead and get started
alright so right here under my vpc
we're going to add another resource and
that resource is aws underscore subnet
just like so and then let's go ahead and
name it i'll just use mtc underscore
public underscore subnet just like so
and you don't always have to add a
prefix like this
although i've been doing it for so long
if i did not add this prefix this course
would be way too long due to all the
errors i'd make so for consistency's
sake i'm just going to keep this mtc
prefix on all of my resources alright so
let's go ahead and open and close those
resource braces and what we need to do
is provide a vpc id now as you remember
when we ran our terraform state list
we've got a list of our resources
and this is how we want to access this
vpc resource so what we're going to do
is awsvpc.mtc
underscore vpc which again matches this
as well and since this is another
resource it's like a variable it's not a
string so you're not going to quote this
this is a reference to a resource so you
don't need to add quotes and then what
we need to do is just specify an id so
if i do the terraform state show aws
vpc.mtc vpc just like so we can see that
it has an id attribute
and that's the id that we need for our
subnet
so we just specify that dot id right
there and that's how you're going to
reference most of the resources that you
have to reference from other resources
so next we need to provide our cider
block
and that's going to equal 10.123 and i'm
just going to say dot 1.0
24 which of course is one of the subnets
within this slash 16. and then after
that we're going to add our map
public ip on launch that's a long one
there
equals true and since this is a boolean
it's also not quoted and then we need to
provide an availability zone just like
so
and that'll be us west and we're just
going to use 2a or at least i am because
i know a is probably good to go
there are ways to use what are called
data sources to ensure that this is
always correct especially if you're
using multiple availability zones but
we're not going to dive into that now
but feel free of course to research that
if you are curious so next up we're
going to add tags
and that name equals
dev
public we'll just go with that so the
vpc we just named dev and we'll just
name this here as dev public so that we
know that it's a public subnet
again map public ipa on launch equals
true is a good reason for us to want to
make sure we label it correctly so we
don't accidentally put sensitive
resources in this subnet which of course
could cause a security nightmare alright
so that's all we have to do for this
subnet
let's go ahead and run our terraform
plan
all right we've got one resource to add
so that's good and aws subnet is going
to get added as you can see everything
we have specified is listed here
and of course certain things like the id
are known after apply so let's go ahead
and run a terraform apply
and then i'm just going to add auto
approve you're not always going to do
this but if you're running a plan first
it's usually pretty safe to go ahead and
just auto approve it
and not have to type that yes every
single time this especially is useful in
automation so i'll go ahead and run this
all right one added everything looks
successful
so go ahead and click on this sprocket
next to resources which again is in the
aws pane and i'll go ahead and type
subnet as you can see we actually do not
have subnets available this is a
limitation of this aws plugin so we're
not going to worry about it but it looks
like that subnet creation was successful
and of course you can always go into the
aws console to verify we're going to
give our resources a way to the internet
by creating an internet gateway we'll
then introduce terraform format to clean
up our code a little bit
so
let's get started as you can see here
the internet gateway is pretty
straightforward it's actually a really
simple resource to deploy we've got a
few attributes here these are the things
that will be exported within our state
and these are the arguments vpc id tags
and default tags
so let's just go ahead and knock this
out all right so here we are let's go
ahead and scroll down a little bit under
our subnet and we will add a new
resource
aws
internet
gateway just like so
and we'll call that the mtc internet
gateway
all right and then i will open and close
my braces
let's add that vpc id
and remember how we access this vpc
awsvpc.mtcvpc.id
just like so in fact
i can even copy this to save a little
bit of time and just paste it in and
then just for the heck of it i'm going
to go ahead and add some tags
and we'll give it a name of
dev
igw just like so
so we've got our dev vpc our dev public
and our dev igw so once we've done that
that's literally all we've got to do
but let's go ahead and introduce that
fun new command
if you go ahead and run a terraform fmt
just like so what that just did was that
corrected any type of inconsistencies
we've got in formatting
as you can see main.tf and providers.tf
were both corrected now unfortunately i
was not scrolled up but as you can see
now all of our equal signs are lined up
perfectly so it made some very minor
formatting changes but it looks a whole
lot better
so that's great and if you want to see
it in action just go ahead and
move that a little bit
run the command again and as you can see
it automatically corrects
alright so let's go ahead and deploy
this brand new internet gateway
go ahead and run terraform
plan just like so
all right one to add as you can see
we've got our internet gateway that's
going to get added
let's go ahead and run a terraform apply
auto approve just like so
okay apply complete everything looks
good let's click on our aws pane and
let's see if we can access this resource
i'll just go ahead and type internet
aha aws internet gateway we've got it so
let's go ahead and check that and select
ok
and if i expand my resources here and
take a look under ec2 internet gateway
we'll see we've got two
so if i click on the one with the longer
id
we can see right here that we've got our
internet gateway
with the proper tag we're going to
create a route table to route traffic
from our subnet to our internet gateway
all right here i am in the docs and as
you can see there's a note here
and basically you can use a standalone
route resource
or you can define routes in line
now in this case they have the routes to
in line just like so we're going to do
it a little bit differently we're
actually going to use a route resource
which as you can see here is also fairly
straightforward and we'll walk through
this here shortly so let's head back
over to our route table as you can see
all we basically need is the vpc id and
then we'll provide some tax
so let's go ahead and do that so i'll
open my main.tf once again scroll down
some let's go ahead and create that
resource aws route table just like so
mtc public rt just to keep it from
getting too long
and open and close our resource braces
and within here we need to provide that
vpc id again
and as always i'll just copy this and
paste it right there and then we'll add
some tags
name equals dev
public
rt
just like so so now that we've done that
once again remember we then need to add
the aws route which is right here and
basically we need to specify a route
table id
destination citer block
and in our case an internet gateway so
let's go ahead and do that so we'll
create that resource
aws route just like so
default route is what we'll call it this
is a default route of course for all
traffic to get to the internet
open and close those resource braces
route table id
equals and we're going to need to use
the aws route table mtc public rt
aws route table dot mtc
public rt and once again all we need to
specify is the id it's asking for an id
and pretty much universally all aws
resources are going to have this id
attribute
so then we need a destination
cider block just like so
and that's going to be 0.0.0.0
which means all ip addresses will head
for this internet gateway and then again
that gateway id
is now going to be aws internet
gateway just like so dot mtc
and as you can see vs code is providing
me some nice little hints so i'm just
going to hit tab internet gateway
dot id
just like so and if we scroll up we can
see mtc internet gateway right here
all right perfect that's all we need to
add so let's go ahead and i'm going to
scroll this up
let's go ahead and run that terraform
plan
and we should have two resources to add
this time
perfect two to add we've got our route
table
and we've got our
route
so that's great let's go ahead and run
our terraform apply auto approve
and everything was applied successfully
let's go ahead and click on the little
sprocket next to resources and see what
we have to offer
so what we've deployed is a route table
aws ec2 route table great
and then i actually do not see a route
that we want to use so we're just going
to take a look at the route table
all right here it is
it's going to be one of these
dev public route table
perfect we're going to bridge the gap
between our route table and our subnet
by providing a route table association
so let's go ahead and get started as you
can see here in the docs the aws route
table association is actually pretty
straightforward basically we just need
to access our subnet and our route table
id
and just specify both of those in an
association
so let's go ahead and knock that out
alright so i'm going to go ahead and
scroll down under this route here
resource
then aws route table
association probably one of the longer
resource names
mtc
public and i'll just call it a sock
there
and open and close my resource braces
we need to provide our subnet id
and that we just scroll up and take a
look
aws subnet mtc public subnet and then
once again we just need to provide the
id of that so
aws
subnet auto complete that dot
mtc
scroll down here public subnet remove
some typing and potential for errors
dot id
just like so so that's all we've got to
do there
then we need to provide a route table id
and that once again we can just copy
right from here
and paste in
all right so that is literally it let's
go ahead and save
and then i'm also going to run another
terraform fmt just to clean things up
look at that much more beautiful
all right and then let's go ahead and
run our terraform plan
perfect one to add our route table
association
and we'll run a terraform apply auto
approve
all right that is all set and all done
and if we want to see that association
and some of the other things we've
created we can't access those from the
resources so of course we can always go
to the console here
we can access the vpc area
head to route tables
we've got our dev public rt right here
take a look at our subnet associations
and there it is our dev public subnet is
associated with this route table
we're going to add a very important
resource to our deployment the security
group so here we are on the
documentation as you can see here is an
illustration of the usage of a security
group now in this case they've actually
defined the ingress and egress in line
which is perfectly fine
now you can specify them separately as
you can see by this note
as a security group rule resource just
like we did with a route resource
but this is perfectly fine now in your
organization you may find a benefit to
adding separate resources but in our
case
this will work perfectly so as you can
see here the egress actually allows
egress to everything on any protocol
that's zero to zero
and then the protocol is negative one
which means udp tcp icmp etc any
protocol you need to use negative one
will cover it now the ingress only
allows port 443 but we actually want to
allow everything we're just going to
ensure that we hard code this ip to our
own ip so that we don't allow someone to
compromise our instance so let's go
ahead and get started now sometimes i
might actually choose to just copy this
and paste it into my ide and then modify
from there to simplify things but since
this documentation may have changed by
the time you watch this we're going to
type it out manually
so let's go ahead and start that
we're going to add our resource like
always
aws
security group just like so
and let's just name that mtcsg for right
now we'll open and close those resource
braces
we'll create a name
that's dev sg sounds good to me now keep
in mind we don't need a tag here because
the security groups actually have a name
attribute
so there's no point in having to tag it
you of course could tag it for other
organizational reasons but as far as the
name goes this is perfectly fine
after that we need to provide a
description
dev security group sounds great to me
we then need to provide a vpc id which
we've used many many times i'm actually
going to just scroll up
copy this
and paste it down here just like so
and then we need to provide our ingress
and egress so let's go ahead and add our
ingress here
from port
make sure you have that underscore there
from port equals zero
to port equals zero
protocol
equals
in quotes here negative one this is
presented like a string terraform is not
going to honor this negative right here
this dash so make sure you specify this
as a string
and then cider blocks equals
now i'm just going to put in 0.0.0.0.0
because i don't want to show everyone my
ip address
make sure you only add your own ip
address here so you can go to what's my
ip or somewhere else to find your ip
address and then that will be something
something something something slash 32
that slash 32 indicates you want to use
only this address
but again i'm just going to put anything
for right now and i'll be sure to
destroy my infrastructure that has this
open port and replace it with my own
later now as you notice this is cider
blocks
with an s
which indicates that it expects a list
now these brackets allow you to enter a
list so if you had multiple ips you
could put a comma here
and specify another one after that
but we only need one all right so our
ingress is taken care of
now let's set up our egress
i'm gonna slide this down a little bit
there we go
egress
from port equals zero
to port equals zero
protocol once again equals negative one
insider blocks in this case i'm going to
allow whatever goes into this subnet to
access anything so you won't put your ip
address here you will make sure you
allow it to access the open internet all
right perfect
so that's all we need to do there
let's run a terraform fmt to clean that
up there we go beautiful now let's go
ahead and run a terraform plan and make
sure everything works out
slide that up okay one to add like we
expected looks like everything looks
good here from port zero protocol
negative one two port zero
perfect let's go ahead and run that
terraform apply
auto approve
all right all complete
let's scroll over to
our aws console
i will click on security groups
go ahead and refresh that page here is
our dev sg
if i open that
click on edit inbound rules we can see
all traffic is allowed on all protocols
all ports
custom source and again in my case is
0.0.0.0
0.
all right perfect
we're almost to the deployment of our
ec2 instance but first we need to
provide the ami from which we want to
deploy to do this we can utilize what's
called a data source a data source is
basically just a query of the aws api to
receive information needed to deploy a
resource in this case
we need an ami id based on some filters
we're going to provide so let's get
started so if i head over here to my
data source documents here for the aws
ami you can see an example data aws ami
and of course data basically is like the
resource keyword we've been using we're
just using data now aws ami is the name
of this data source and of course this
needs to stay the same no matter what
and then this here can be whatever you
want to name it now we'll be using most
recent and we'll be using some filters
as well now one thing we have to make
sure is that we have the correct owner
now one way to do that is to use aws
marketplace but in our case we're going
to be a little more specific let's take
a look at how to get the owner id we
need
so if i head into the management console
here
i'm going to type ec2 up at the top
going to open that
and if i go to instances and launch
instance
let's take a look i'm just going to type
up unto here
and i'm going to deploy ubuntu server
1804 that's one i've used in my other
courses and i'm just going to stick to
that for now 2004 should work perfectly
fine and whatever it is you want you can
choose but in our case we're just going
to use this 1804 so what i'm going to do
is copy this ami id because an owner id
is not provided here which is a little
annoying and then i'm going to head back
to my ec2 console
and i'm going to click on amis under
images and right there make sure you
have public images chosen
and enter that ami id
and here is our owner so go ahead and
copy that you're going to need it here
shortly alright so once we have that
let's head back over and start coding
this thing out let me drop this a little
give us some room so now what i'm going
to do is actually create a new file for
this we're going to call it
datasources.tf
so i'll just create a new file
and datasources.tf
just like so
and this will just keep things a little
cleaner so we'll use data
aws ami
and we'll just call it our server ami or
whatever you want to call it we want to
specify most recent equals true
and then we provide the owners
now the owners as you can see is plural
so we're actually going to use brackets
which makes it a list go ahead and paste
that owner id that we got into here
and of course if there are other owners
you could but in this case we just need
that owner id
all right now that we have provided our
owners here let's go ahead and provide a
filter to get the correct ami
so if i type filter
just like so
name equals and we're going to filter on
name i know this looks a little
confusing but the filter name is
actually name
and then values equals
and once again this is plural so make
sure it's in brackets
ubuntu
slash images
slash hvm
ssd slash ubuntu
bionic
dash 18.04
dash amd 64. make sure you have the
right architecture there
dash server
dash and then what we're going to do
since there's usually a date here and
we're just going to pull the most recent
no matter what we're just going to add
an asterisk so instead of the date that
we would use here we use an asterisk so
that any date will qualify so if i just
head right back over here and take a
look you can see
basically all we're doing
is just putting an asterisk instead of
this date but everything else is exactly
the same
alright so perfect so that's actually
all we need to do go ahead and save this
file
and then let's go ahead and run a
terraform apply
terraform apply
auto
approve just like so
all right great so now that is applied
so if i open my terraform.tf state right
here again you would usually use a
terraform show but this is a little bit
easier for this
we can scroll down under resources
and you can actually see we have
instances even though we don't have any
ec2 instances actually deployed there's
still an instances section that contains
this ami data source and if you look
down you can actually see
we've got an image id right here which
actually does not match here and there's
a reason for that and that is if you
look at the date 2021
1129 the date of this one is actually
2022-0104
so this is actually a newer instance
than what is in the console which is why
that ami doesn't match and for our
purposes that's perfectly fine we're
going to create a key pair and then
create a terraform resource that
utilizes this key pair
this will be used by the ec2 instance
resource we create so that we can ssh
into it later so
let's get started alright i'm going to
first highlight my main.tf here and then
i'm going to go ahead and create that
key pair
so to do that and yes i am on windows
windows actually does have an ssh
utility so i'm going to run the same
commands that i would run on os x or
linux ssh dash keygen
dash t
and we will use a more secure key than
the typical rsa we use let's use ed25519
and hit enter now we're going to rename
this key pair here i'm just going to
copy
this instead of retyping it basically
everything before the id ed25519
and i'm going to paste that in and then
we're just going to name this mtc key or
at least i am name it whatever you want
here just make sure you reference it
properly throughout the rest of the
course and i'll hit enter we're not
going to bother with a passphrase all
right perfect looks like everything is
good to go just going to run an ls
tilled slash dot ssh here
and that shows me that directory
and mtc key is there and mtc key dot pub
which is what we'll use for our key
resource so now let's take a look at the
docs as we usually do
resource aws key pair as you see we
basically need to specify a resource aws
key pair and then name that whatever we
need to we'll give it a name
and then we will provide the public key
now we could just copy and paste the
public key from our file
but that looks very very messy
so what we're going to do
is use a terraform function we're going
to use the file function so all we have
to do is utilize file and then enter the
path to our key and what that will allow
us to do is specify the key just like
this only
much shorter by just passing in a path
instead of the full public key
so let's go ahead and do that so
we'll start with resource
aws key pair just like so after that i'm
just going to call it mtc off
open and close those resource braces
key name i'm going to go ahead and call
that mtc key just to keep things simple
and then we need to pass in that public
key
and to do that we're going to utilize
the file function
and we'll quote this and i'll use that
tild
slash dot ssh
slash mtc key
dot pub
and again i'm on windows but these
commands should all pretty much line up
and be the same so i'm going to go ahead
and save that going to run a terraform
plan
make sure everything looks good i'll
scroll up here a little bit
all right perfect so the key pair will
be created looks like everything passed
those initial checks
so i'll run a terraform apply
auto approve just like so
all right apply complete
so if i take a look over here in my aws
resources we can see if this is one that
is available for us so i'll just type in
key
unfortunately key pair does not appear
to be one that we can see right here
from this screen
so we'll just head back into the ec2
console i'll click on key pairs
and there it is mtc key type ed25519
everything looks great
we're going to finally deploy our ec2
instance
it won't have anything installed on it
yet but we'll at least get it scaffolded
and deployed
so let's get started all right we take a
look at our docs here the resource is
actually called aws instance as you can
see in the basic example it's using an
ami lookup which looks very similar to
what we have used before as you can see
it's got the owner it's got everything
else here of course we already saw how
to get the owner id ourself so that's
great and then basically we just need to
provide that ami and you reference that
by using the data keyword
dot aws underscore ami dot ubuntu id so
do keep that in mind where typically
with a resource we would just use aws
vpc.myvpc.id for instance but with a
data source you need to prepend that
with the word data and then we'll just
provide a few more arguments as you can
see there are a lot of arguments for the
ec2 instance so let's go ahead and start
coding this thing out all right so what
i'm going to do
let's scroll this down a little bit and
let's add our resource
aws instance just like so and i'll just
call this dev node just like so
open and close those resource braces we
need to provide an instance type
first and to keep this in the free tier
we will use a t2.micro of course you can
scale that up but that might cost you
some money and then we need to provide
our ami so as you remember
the ami in our data source here is data
dot aws ami dot server ami
so data dot aws underscore ami dot
server
ami
just like so and then we just need to
add id to the end
and then let's add some tags we'll just
give it a name
equals
and we'll call it dev dash node just
like so now after that
we need to provide our key name
which of course we created recently and
what we're going to use is aws
key pair
which of course we just created right
here
dot mtc underscore auth
dot id once again now i see that this
says key name and not necessarily id but
the id is perfectly fine here the id
will work now if you take a look by just
running terraform state show aws key
pair
dot mtc underscore auth
we can see there actually is a key name
so if you want to be more explicit you
can absolutely use key name id is just a
force of habit it's something that i do
frequently as you can see it is the same
for both
so both works perfectly fine but just
know you can use key underscore name if
you want to be more explicit alright so
now that we've done that
let's go ahead and give this ec2
instance a security group vpc
security group
ids you see this s here which means you
guessed it we need to use brackets and
i'm just going to do aws underscore
security and tab there to autofill that
dot mtc
underscore sg
right there
dot id
and of course if you have multiple you
can
use comma separation to provide multiple
security groups and then we just need a
subnet id
so that's going to be aws
subnet dot
mtc underscore public
subnet just like so dot id
then if we want to resize the default
size of the
drive on this instance we can provide
root
block device just like so
and you can actually up this we can say
volume
size equals
you could say we'll just say 10 we'll
keep it in the free tier which gives you
16. so we'll just say volume size equals
10 which is larger than the 8 that they
give you by default alright so that
actually is all we need to add for our
instance for now let's go ahead and run
our terraform plan
all right as you can see we've got a lot
of attributes there but everything looks
good to go
but actually don't bother applying yet
we're going to go ahead and come on back
to the next lesson and add some user
data before we apply this instance so we
don't have to wait for it and then just
redestroy it we're going to utilize user
data to bootstrap our instance and
install the docker engine this will
allow us to have an ec2 instance
deployed with docker ready to go for all
of our development needs so
let's get started now the first thing
i'm going to do is just clean up this
aws instance a little bit i'm going to
cut this out
and i'm just going to take everything
that's not in a block
and place it together so this will make
things look a little more streamlined
so as you can see we've got all of our
arguments here
followed by the tags block and the root
device block and just to be consistent
i'm actually going to cut out this root
device block and put it above the tags
block since almost everywhere
we finish the resource with tags alright
perfect so that looks a lot better so
now let's add this user data first thing
i want to do is create the user data
file
so i'll create a new file
and let's just call it userdata.tpl
now this tpl actually stands for
template we're not using this as a
template right now
but just in case in the future you
decide to use it as a template you can
and we'll take a look at templating here
in the coming lessons all right so go
ahead and take that script i've provided
in this lesson and paste that in now
this script as you can see is going to
update apt it's going to
install some dependencies it's going to
download the docker gpg key it's going
to add the docker repository
update once again
install docker
and then it's going to add ubuntu to the
docker group allowing you to run docker
commands as the ubuntu user
i know that was a little quick feel free
to reach out if you have any questions
so now that we've got this in it's in
our userdata.tp script and i have saved
it and this is in our root directory
let's head back to our main.tf
and let's go ahead and add this user
data to our resource
so what i'll do is just add user
underscore data
equals
and we're just going to use the file
function here and in quotes once again
userdata.tpl
so what this is going to do
is extract the contents from our
userdata.tpl file and use that to
bootstrap our instance
so perfect let's go ahead and see if
everything works let's run a terraform
plan
all right one to add as you can see
we've got our ec2 instance here
everything's looking pretty good as you
can see our user data is
hashed here so if this user data were to
change it actually would change that
hash and indicate that we need to
redeploy our instance so that's really
really useful
so now let's go ahead and apply
terraform apply
auto approve just like so
now this is going to take a little bit
so feel free to pause
and then come on back whenever your
instance is deployed
all right as you can see the apply is
complete i'm going to head into my ec2
console
just like so
and as you can see it's running and i've
actually had a few dead ones here but
this new one is running but it's still
initializing so go ahead and pause the
video once again hit refresh a few times
and come on back whenever the status
check is green
alright so now everything is green we've
got two of two checks passed perfect
so now let's ssh into the instance first
of all i need that ip address so we can
definitely just copy it from right here
but another way of course is to use our
terraform state so if we do a terraform
state list just like so we then see our
instance right here
i'm just going to copy that
then i'm going to do a terraform state
show
and hit that instance right there
and here is all of the information we
can get and if i scroll up a little bit
i've got the public ip address right
here perfect
so now what i'm going to do is just do
it ssh dash i
then if you're on linux or windows you
can use the tild slash dot ssh slash
mtc key or whatever you name that key
now if i hit tab that will actually
correct it for windows users but it
doesn't matter it works either way
and then i'm just going to use my ubuntu
username at
and that public ip address
and hit enter type yes and bam we are in
the instance now
so if i run a docker
version
as you can see we now have docker
installed and the instance is running
we're going to take a look at the
configuration we're going to have to
create
to allow vs code to connect to our ec2
instance so first of all if you haven't
already head over to the extensions
and go ahead and search for ssh
and you should see this remote ssh app
here
go ahead and install that extension
just like so
all right perfect so now that we've done
that
you can go ahead and head back to the
explorer
and first thing i want to do is take a
look at some example config files
so you should have a file now
at your home
slash dot ssh slash config
so if i do cat
ssh config just like so
i can see here
that i already have two entries of
course this is something i've done
before and what we need is we need to
provide a host
a host name which happened to be the
same here and a user that we're going to
use to log in
so what we need to do is provide the ip
address of our instance on both of these
host areas host and host name
and then we'll utilize ubuntu
for the user so how are we going to do
that
what we're going to do is we're going to
use
template files and we'll take a look
into that very soon
but first let's create the files
so go ahead and create a file based on
your operating system whether you're on
windows or linux or mac linux and mac
can both use the same script windows is
going to be different so i'm going to
create both in this lesson first i'm
just going to create windows dash ssh
config.tpl just like so and if you're on
windows go ahead and grab that script
copy it
and paste it in
so basically what this is doing and
you'll need to replace your username
here mine of course is derek yours
probably isn't derek but you might be go
ahead and replace that
and then this is going to add the host
hostname user and an identity file which
we didn't see before but we do require
to our config
now what we do is we actually specify
the hostname the user and identity file
from our main.tf
and we're going to take a look at how to
do that in the coming lessons so go
ahead and save this file if you're
windows
and if you're linux let's go ahead and
create that one
so again you can call this mac if you
want i'm just going to call linux ssh
config for our file name
and this will serve for either mac or
linux and for that go ahead and copy the
script and paste it in
what we've got here is we're actually
cadding into home.ssh
config and then we've got the host
hostname hostname user and identity file
just as we did before
so go ahead and save that file if your
linux you can also provide both if you
utilize
both platforms like i do we're going to
utilize a provisioner to configure the
vs code on our local terminal to be able
to ssh into our ec2 instance
now a provisioner is not something you
want to use for every deployment
unlike other resources a provisioner's
success or failure will not be recorded
or managed by terraform state so if
something goes wrong that's just too bad
there's no rollback or any other way to
manage it other than just running it
again
while this is not good for configuring
remote instances it's perfectly fine for
something like this
all we're going to be doing is adding
information to a config file on our
local terminal this is a lightweight
operation that doesn't affect the
overall success of the deployment if
something were to go wrong so with that
being said let's get started
first we'll take a look over here at the
provisioner documents
as you can see provisioners are a last
resort
generally speaking you're going to want
to use user data which of course we do
ansible or
packer or chef or something else some
other configuration management tool if
there's some sort of configuration we
need to do on a remote instance but once
again on our situation it's perfectly
fine
and we can use the local exec
provisioner to allow us to configure
local machines and run local commands as
you can see basically we're running a
provisioner and in this case a local
exec provisioner within
an aws instance resource provisioners
are always run within another resource
this could be something called a null
resource also
but we're not going to look into that
right now now another thing we're going
to use is this self object here
which basically allows us to access this
instance and access information so if we
need a private ip or public ip or
whatever we're able to access that right
here
using this self attribute now something
else you might notice we've got this
dollar sign
and braces here
that is interpolation syntax and
basically what that means is this is
going to be replaced by whatever it is
we're trying to use
so we've got a string here
but this here will be replaced by the
private ip of this aws instance and you
may have remembered that in our previous
scripts so let's go ahead and just get
to work so right over here once again we
can take a look at our configuration
files
and once again remember these here the
same syntax these are going to be
replaced
by the host name the user identity file
whatever we need to pass in so let's go
ahead and start typing
our provisioner i'm going to go to the
bottom of our instance resource here
we're going to type provisioner
just like so
and then local
dash exec
we've been using underscores a lot
throughout this script as you remember
but this provisioner uses a dash make
sure you remember that this is a dash or
a hyphen and not an underscore this is a
mistake i have made many many times open
and close that provisioner block next up
we provide our command now this command
is actually going to be run from these
files here and to run these files and
pass in the variables necessary
we won't use the file function we'll use
what's called the template file function
so we take a look at the template file
function here you can see that basically
you pass in vars after you pass in the
path so for instance you can take a look
at here template file and then this here
is the path which is using this
interpolation syntax and path.module
which is a built-in variable and then
you use a comma
and then within an object here with
these curly braces you pass in the
variables that you need to pass in so
let's go ahead and do that
so for the path
in my case since i'm on a windows
machine i'm just going to use quotes
windows dash ssh dash config dot tpl
just like so if you are on linux or mac
you'll use the linux version
and then after that we need to pass in
our variables so i'll add a comma here
then open and close some curly braces
and we will pass in these variables i'm
actually going to indent this
first up we need our hostname
remember we had to pass in a hostname
there
and that hostname is going to be self
dot public underscore ip
remember we have a public ip attribute
for our instance that we used before
whenever we sshed into it
so we can just use self.publicip here to
access that after that we need to
provide the user and that's going to be
ubuntu because that is the ec2 instance
username that we have after that we need
to provide an identity file
so that identity file is going to be our
private key
and the private key is located
we'll just use a tild here slash dot ssh
slash mtc key just like so
alright so that is all of the variables
we need to pass in
and then after that we need to pass in
an interpreter now the interpreter
basically just tells our provisioner
what it needs to use to run this script
now it defaults to bash so you don't
necessarily need to add this for that
but we will just to be sure so i'm going
to add interpreter just like so
equals
and since i'm on windows we're going to
use powershell
and then we need to pass in the next
command which is dash
command
now if you are on linux and do not put
both of these here i'm just using this
as an example
for interpreter
you're going to use
bash and we'll have a comma here
and then dash
c
is the interpreter you'll use for linux
but again i'm on windows so i'm going to
delete that and keep this here all right
so once you've done that that is
everything we need to do and this will
hopefully create our instance and it
will replace the hostname with
self.public ip the user with ubuntu and
the identity file with this key here so
let's go ahead and give it a shot now
the first thing we need to do is we need
to run a terraform plan
pull this up some
as you can see
we've got no changes here that's because
the provisioner does not affect our
state it doesn't read that there's a
provisioner there and it's not going to
change anything just because we added
one we are going to redeploy our ec2
instance and finally see if everything
works so hopefully when we redeploy this
instance this provisioner is going to
run add the information required to our
configuration file and allow us to ssh
into the instance without any issues so
let's go ahead and give it a shot so
first up once again i'm just going to
run that terraform plan
and as you can see
no changes which means
that this provisioner is not going to
run because terraform hasn't detected
anything different
once again it does not detect
provisioners as differences in the state
so it's not going to trigger a run so
let's go ahead and take a look at a way
that we can trigger that run first up
i'm just going to run a terraform state
list again
and of course we've got our aws
instance.dev node go ahead and highlight
that and copy it
and then what we want to do is use a new
command we haven't used or at least a
new flag
we've used terraform apply a lot
but now what we're going to use is a
dash replace
now this used to be known as terraform
tanked which would actually
cause a resource to be replaced on the
next run
but now instead we just use dash replace
i'll go ahead and paste in this
instance.dev node here and let's hit
enter alright as you can see we are
refreshing the state
okay now we've got one to destroy and
one to add so
it is removing and replacing our
instance
and once that happens it should run our
local exec
replacing the content in our config file
with what we need
and allowing us to ssh into our instance
from vs code
so let's go ahead and type yes and pause
this video
come on back whenever it's done of
course you might want to hop into the
ec2 console
and once the instance shows up is
running and has two of two complete and
green go ahead and come on back and
we'll see if everything worked
all right all of my checks are passed
here let's go ahead and bring our editor
back over
and this is now the moment of truth
first things first i'm just going to cat
my ssh config file
and this is a really good sign look at
that it looks like our provisioner did
exactly what we asked it to it added the
ip address the hostname our user
and the identity file
to our config file
so now that that's happened let's head
up to
view
command palette
and let's just type in ssh right here
and as you can see remote ssh connect to
host
click on that
and hey check that out so we've already
got our ip address ready to go let's
click on it
opens a new window
this is a linux host again we're on a
windows terminal or i am but it's a
linux host so choose linux here
yes we are sure we'd like to continue
looks like everything is setting up
downloading installing vs code server
all right let's open a terminal terminal
new terminal
bam check that out and if we run docker
docker is nice and installed once again
we can do a docker dash dash version
so now we have a perfectly good
development environment ready to go you
can open up folders on the remote once
again home ubuntu is a remote folder
so if i run that i am now in a fully
remote terminal
go ahead i can hit trust these authors
bam perfect so this is really really
cool
we're going to start optimizing our
script and making it more dynamic by
adding variables
so let's get started now so far we've
hard coded pretty much everything so now
it's time to modify that to give us some
flexibility so that we can adjust things
easily without having to fish through
every single attribute here and instead
being able to go to one file and modify
what we need there for instance
probably one of the things we're going
to modify the most is the type of os
we're using so since for instance i use
mac windows and linux quite frequently
there's a good chance i'm going to want
to be able to modify which type of
instance i'm using on the fly so let's
go ahead and take a look at that now
first of all what i want to do is i want
to use interpolation syntax to specify a
variable here now basically that
variable will be calculated whenever we
apply our script so i'm going to use
interpolation syntax which i've
mentioned before and basically that's
going to be a dollar sign
and two curly braces just like that
so whatever happens here is going to be
calculated dynamically whenever we run
our script so let's go ahead and name
this variable we'll call it var
dot host underscore os
so anywhere we need a variable you
specify it with var dot variable name
just like so so now if i choose windows
then it will be windows dash ssh dash
config
linux linux dash ssh dash config just
like so so now what we need to do is we
need to initialize this variable and
specify that hey
we've got a variable that we're going to
need to define and to do that we could
either do it here in line in the main.tf
or what i prefer to do and most everyone
is to create a new file for it so i'm
going to create a variables.tf file
once again it's analyzed just like any
other tf file it's all run at the same
time but this will just make sure that
it's easier to find our variables when
we need them now you can take a look
here at the input variables
documentation
declaring an input variable is actually
fairly straightforward you use the
variable
variable name and then within braces you
give it a type and you can also give it
a default now the type is not
necessarily required but it is strongly
recommended so that your other devops
co-workers don't lose their minds trying
to figure out what type of variable is
expected so let's head back over here
and let's go ahead and build this
so it's going to be a variable once
again
host underscore os
then we'll use our curly braces
and we'll just provide a type and that
type equals string we're not going to
bother with a default yet but we'll get
to it so now that we've done that let's
actually go ahead and
perform a terraform destroy auto approve
and as you can see here
it's actually asking for this variable
to be defined now
so keep that in mind anytime you add a
new variable any destroy apply or
plan operation is going to require that
you define those variables
and we'll look at other ways to define
them so that we don't have it popping up
every time here from the command line
but for right now we can just define it
dynamically so let's just go ahead and
i'm going to say windows if you're on
mac or linux specify linux but again
nothing really matters now because
nothing is running
so go ahead and destroy this
infrastructure
the video and come on back whenever it's
destroyed
alright so everything is destroyed here
and just to illustrate once again if i
run a terraform plan
it is going to ask me for that variable
so if i type that in then the plan will
run so keep that in mind again if you
have variables that are not set
a plan apply or destroy is going to ask
for those variables so if you're in
automation that can break your
automation we've now seen how to
initialize a variable and how to define
it at the command line but as we saw
that is not a great way to define
variables when in automation as it
requires dynamic input which is the
opposite of automated so in this lesson
we're going to look at a few other ways
to define variables and which of those
ways take precedence over the others so
let's get started so first of all let's
take a look at the docs again and if you
scroll a good bit down you can kind of
see like we've got default values custom
validation rules we've got a lot here
that's actually really good information
but what we really want to see is if you
scroll all the way down you can see
variable definition precedence
so basically environment variables are
processed last so as we go down this
list
these are processed
in front of the other so environment
variables are processed last so if you
have an environment variable set but
then you define a variable in
terraform.tf vars which we're going to
look at then
terraform.tf terraform.tfvars is the
variable we're going to use and then
you've got
terraform.tfvrs.json which not too many
people use but you can use it in
automation it does help sometimes you've
then got auto.tfvars and
auto.tfvrs.json which are used in
terraform cloud quite frequently and
then you can specify a var and var file
option on the command line
but this isn't like a dynamic definition
it's not like it asks you for the
definition and you type it you just add
this dash var switch and then you
provide the definition and we will look
at that so let's go ahead and just take
a look what we're going to do is
run the terraform console and this is a
really good tool that will help you work
with certain functions and play with
different values and things like that
that you might need to experiment with
before you deploy so if you run
terraform console let's just take a look
as you can see it did not ask us for a
variable so if i run var.host underscore
os
you can see it's known after apply so
until we actually apply and specify that
variable then our terraform console has
no idea what that host os variable is so
i'm going to go ahead and type exit to
get out of the console
and what i'm going to do first is just
add a default here so go ahead and add
default equals
and then specify your host
which again mine is windows yours might
be linux so now let's go ahead and run a
terraform console and let's run var.host
underscore os
there you go so now it has processed it
basically terraform console has looked
at all of our configuration files and
saw that we have a default of windows so
that's awesome alright so i'm going to
get out of the console once again now
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a new file
and we're going to call that
terraform.tfvars
just like so
now this is the default name for our
variable definition file so here all we
need to do is define the variable
so host os equals
windows
or you know what i'm just going to type
linux since we're not running this right
now so now let's run a terraform console
just like so and let's run var.host os
now it's linux as you can see
terraform.tf vars takes precedence over
a default variable set within the
variables.tf all right so that's great
so now i'm going to get out of the
console again
now let's say we have i don't know a
unix system or we want a different
script that only works with osx and we
want to specify that now if we still
have these two files how are we going to
override this value now that we have it
defined in terraform.tfrs
well there are a few ways to do that and
one way is to specify the variable in
line with our command so if i run
terraform console
dash var equals
and we'll just say host os equals and
unix just like so
now var.host underscore os
is unix
so if you need to override
everything that you have specified in
any file anywhere you specify it right
here in line and again this could be a
terraform apply or terraform plan that
you specify this var for and this will
override any other files that you've got
so now let's take a look at one more
scenario i'm going to exit once again
let's say that we have a dev.tfrs
now what matters is the tf vars not
necessarily the word in front
however terraform is going to process
anything in
terraform.tfrs by default so if you have
a dev.tfrs and let's say that was host
os equals osx
just like so we run a terraform console
and then we run var.host os
as you can see it's still linux
not os x so if we want to pass in this
file
we just need to run terraform console
dash var dash file
equals
dev dot tf vars just like so and now
let's take a look var.host underscore os
is now os x perfect so now we've seen
most of the ways that terraform will
process variables and the precedence it
uses to decide which variable to use so
now that we've managed to choose our ssh
config file dynamically based on the
definition of our host os variable we
now need to make our interpreter dynamic
unfortunately this isn't as simple as
interpolation syntax replacements so we
need to look at a better way we're going
to utilize conditional expressions to
choose the interpreter we need
dynamically based on the definition of
the host os variable so let's get
started so what i mean by interpreter of
course is this interpreter here the one
that determines what interpreter is
going to be used to interpret our ssh
config script and if it's windows it's
powershell and if it's linux it's bash
and as you can see we can't just replace
it like we did up here that was very
simple and of course there are ways we
could define this but you know what
since we know that it's only one or the
other based on the host os i don't want
to create a new variable just to do this
i'd much rather just continue using the
same host os variable so if you take a
look at conditionals here conditional
expressions
you can see basically you provide a
condition question mark then you see the
true value
or the false value
so if host os is windows the true value
would be powershell and the false value
could be bash for instance
so let's go ahead and just hop in and
take a look at what this looks like
so i'm going to run the terraform
console
and we're going to pass in a variable
definition of course we have it defined
all over the place up here in our files
but we're just going to define it right
here in line instead of messing with
those files right now so var equals host
underscore os
equals windows for me anyway and enter
let's verify var.host os
windows perfect so what we want to do is
say if
var.host os
equals and we're using two equal signs
here because we're not setting this we
are checking for equality windows
then first we'll just say powershell and
of course this isn't the interpreter
we'll use exactly but just for the sake
of using this now this will be easier
or bash
just like so as you can see we got
powershell now if var.host os
is linux
and we run this same exact command again
powershell
bash
then we get bash so that's pretty
straightforward so what we want is we
actually want this command and the other
command which of course i have also
provided and we're going to use those
instead of just powershell and bash so
we'll say var.host os is windows
then what we want
is in brackets here
powershell comma
dash command just like so and close that
bracket
or if it's not windows if this is false
then we just use
bash
comma
dash c
just like so
let's hit enter
and perfect even though the formatting
is a little wonky there this will be
perfectly fine so go ahead and just copy
this directly ctrl c that and for
interpreter i'm just going to paste that
in just like so and that's all we have
to do so let's go ahead and exit the
console there and let's go up to our
terraform.tf vars
make sure that is set to your os i'm
going to go ahead and change this to
windows since that is the os i am using
variables.tf the default is windows
which is fine because terraform.tfrs is
going to overwrite it anyway so if
that's different that is perfectly fine
but you may want to change this as well
and then once again within our main tf
everything looks good so let's go ahead
and run a terraform plan
all right everything looks like it went
through fine so let's go ahead and apply
it
terraform apply auto approve and
hopefully by the time our instance is
fully initialized we will be able to ssh
into it just like we were able to before
so go ahead and run this terraform apply
pause the video and come on back
whenever your ec2 instance is all green
all right everything has come back just
fine we're running and all green so
let's go ahead and see if this new ip
address is available for ssh i'll
actually take a quick peek
34.219 for this one so i will click on
view command palette i've already got
remote ssh ready to go
and there it is 34.219.24
let's go ahead and see if it works
this is a linux machine
i would like to continue yes
and everything is looking absolutely
fantastic we once again have our
development environment all ready to go
but this time it's dynamic based on the
host os that we're using we're going to
add a nice little convenience feature to
our script by utilizing outputs to
display information we need as you well
know we've been manually finding the
public ip address of our instances to
verify them well that is incredibly
inefficient so let's go ahead and add an
output to make this a little easier so
as you can see we've got output values
here and basically it's incredibly
simple to do so this of course is how to
access a private ip well we're just
going to access the public ip as you can
see we've got a lot of other features as
well such as the ability to mark an
output sensitive so that it doesn't show
up on the command line you've also got a
depends on feature as well we're not
going to dive into that
but we are just going to go ahead and
access that public ip of our instance so
if you run terraform console
you can then access all those attributes
of our instance and kind of play with
them to see what output we're going to
get as you remember it is aws instance
dev node so if we just type aws
underscore instance
dot dev underscore node
dot public
underscore ip
there it is
so that's very very simple and as you
know you can use terraform show or
terraform state show to get all of these
attributes that you could use for
outputs so if i get out of this console
then run a terraform state show
and of course we'll just use once again
aws instance dot dev
node just like so
we can see all of the possibilities that
we can use to output as you can see we
can output instance types and here is
public ip so that's what we did we just
accessed that
so let's go ahead and create this output
what we're going to do
is just create a new file
outputs.tf
once again you could add it to our
main.tf but we just want to clean things
up a little
so output
and we'll just call this devip
open and close those braces
value equals aws instance
dot dev underscore node dot public
ip
just like so that's all we have to do
now to access this output we may not
want to destroy our entire deployment
just because we added an output what we
can do is just run a terraform apply
dash refresh only
and that's basically just going to
consider this output and add it to the
state so that we can get to it
just like so as you can see we've got
changes to outputs
so that's perfect so let's go ahead and
run this
apply complete that's it
and then we can run terraform output
just like so to see our output once
again and this is very very useful in
automation
now if we take a look in our tf state
scroll all the way to the top we can see
our outputs
are right here
so it's very easy to see what we need to
see so outputs are incredibly useful and
there's a whole lot you can do you can
get very creative with what types of
outputs you get but for our purposes all
we need to know is that ip address which
matches the one that we use to ssh into
that instance